love for you guys all just talk about
from the early days of looking at script
and understanding what your director
Antoine who you've all worked with uh
you know numerous times have a long
history
um but maybe let's start with you
Heather
um what could you tell from this film
what was going to be different about it
and what were some of the obvious
challenges even from the early days of
production yes so
so this film for me the minute that I
read this script I knew that it was
going to be the most important film of
my career prior to this I worked on a
bunch of really fun comedies and some
sweet romance dramas and this film felt
so important because of the message and
also the times that we were in in
America it just felt like it was
important to get this message out about
the dangers of hate and Division and
what it can lead to if we're not careful
how we can rewrite history in a horrible
way and so I knew that this was
important because of the message behind
it and while it was going to be
something that would be entertaining in
a way most importantly it would be
thought provoking and inspiring and
hopefully would help people to consider
different perspectives and open up their
minds that I think making any film is
complicated and a huge Challenge and
this one is no exception I think you
guys were up against incredible weather
conditions um I'd love maybe maybe Ed if
you could talk about being on Set uh you
know the post team has the luxury of air
conditioning and controlling of
temperature whereas that was not the
case on the day of I had plenty of air
conditioning
every night for about eight hours maybe
maybe six
Louisiana in the summer I don't know if
you've ever been
nice place to visit keep going
um Hot 100 degrees regularly 100 plus
humidity well into the 90 percent
um storms spend all morning and half the
afternoon picking up and then boom
dumping on you every day afternoon my
Clockwork uh thunder lightning we took
required heat breaks
the people measuring heat index
and you know telling you you've got to
take 10 minutes you've got to take 15
you've got to get out of the Sun
um people people you know really
suffering under really difficult
conditions
let it be said that no matter how
difficult these conditions were and how
much we felt like you know really put
upon
think of the story think of the people
in the story and you realize your
Situation's not that bad
um something I want to talk about is the
opening it's establishing tone
establishing environment
um maybe with Marcelo if you could talk
about that first cue we quickly this the
opening shot coming down into the cotton
field and the first thing we start to
hear is the workers and obviously this
first cue that you introduce talk about
the tone and the choice of
instrumentation that you have
um Antoine um one of the score to
reflect the spirituality of Peter that
was very important but also
the environment that he's in and this
dual spirituality that is both of his
African origins and also his Christian
faith and the music had to kind of like
do both things and I think in that
opening
we we were trying to establish that
sound of the mystery of the forest
there's a sense that Peter kind of
communicates with with the forest and
the forest kind of helps him you know he
he has kind of a
uh very
uh special connection with nature and
and I used a lot of the bimbo which is a
Brazilian instrument it's the first
instrument you hear it sounds like a
guitar and it's a it's a fighting
instrument from Africa that is
associated with uh the Capoeira fight
and I remember
um when I played this for Antoine
originally he was he didn't know what it
was and I didn't want to say what it was
and I just wanted to see if the sound
would do it and it really did him and
Coronet were both very taken with the
sound and and then the voices were very
important
um as well
both the solo sort of like this African
singer we had this wonderful Joe Virgil
incredible uh
soloist who sings a lot of the in a lot
of the the movie but also
um a classical choir and I was having
this again the dichotomy of
his
ancestor spirituality and and the
Christian and also in some ways the
Christian the way I saw it was both a
relief and a source of inspiration for
him to get back to his family but we at
certain points the music kind of shows a
little bit of the oppression as well of
of European culture and and all of the
things that it was uh
sort of
enforcing on that horrible situation
yeah I love for Mandel and David talk
about these the Work Camp because once
we get there we are in the middle uh
we're taking the perspective of of this
in very harsh very dangerous scenario
there's bombs going off in the
background there's you know hammers
hammering railroad tracks it's not a
quiet peaceful situation you guys carry
that tension especially
for a very long time it's a long
sequence and can you guys talk about
building introducing Dynamics in your
track and introducing the environment
because it's their subtleties and
nuances that I feel like especially in
here like you hear everything you can't
escape it
uh yeah well when we first saw the
images of the labor camp we we knew that
it was going to be a large undertaking
um there wasn't a lot of uh production
sound of the environment to be had uh
with Ed capturing the dialogue really
well but just not um we didn't have a
lot of the movement so that all had to
be filled in and with such a wide image
and so much happening in there uh uh we
knew it was going to be a lot of work to
sort of
um address all the detail
um and so but we had a lot to work with
in
um you know all the conditions that uh
Ed had mentioned on set Antoine wanted
us to bring that to the labor camp he
wanted it to be hot and exhausting not
just for uh the the forced laborers but
also for their uh uh the uh the slave
masters as well
um it was just a miserable experience
for for everybody there or it was hot it
was people were just labor labor labor
um uh uh you know the the bombs going
off in the background implied you know
that they're continuing to work even
beyond the scope of the vision their
their their uh being pressured to get
that railroad done in time uh because
the weapons are are coming to uh
reinforce the the war effort
in addition to that Antoine really
wanted the sound to ground the film in
this gritty
uh
unrelenting reality
and so we also tried to add voices to it
and and we quickly learned that uh too
many voices made it too familiar
and so we started removing voices and we
we still had the work and the labor
efforts
um and in the occasional uh slave master
kind of
exerting their Force but it became much
more tense and unsafe and Dangerous by
removing the human voice
and something that had come up was of
the introduction of the preacher
character it's a it's it's a quick
moment in the beginning but then it was
something that had come up that you saw
an opportunity to kind of accentuate
right later on or to capture those
tracks uh the actor Clyde Clyde Jones
right a really good choice I'm gonna
give you credit just just because I can
so Clyde was hired to be the preacher
and he appeared really only one day he
was scheduled as a as a one-day actor
and he added such a spark
um to the to the Ensemble of that was in
the in the Work Camp that they extended
his contract
um and they gave him you know they put
him in more shots and I'd look in my my
monitor and I go oh he's in the Middle
Ground oh wait now he's in the
background oh he's over here but they
didn't give him anything to say and I
realized that that element of what he's
all about is missing
um so I kidnapped him
uh I saw that he had earmarked and
bookmarked in his prop Bible a whole
range of biblical passages and I so I
put him into a into a four by four
off-road vehicle went about a mile away
from the set and generators and noise
and shooting crude all this I said read
all read everything you got everything
that you think is is Meaningful and he
did and you know he bellowed it out as
if he was in the Work Camp and we
recorded uh not only that day but the
next morning at breakfast
um he said hey I got some more
um
4 30 in the morning okay we'll get it
we'll get it so we got him a second time
and I know we Conrad you know the editor
was quite pleased to have all this
material as wild track and you guys use
some of it I guess oh you used quite a
bit and ultimately it became an
important addition that he was uh in his
own way
um trying to make it more palatable for
the slaves that this is God's doing this
is God's work this is a noble thing to
serve their masters and so at some point
we we couldn't feature it it wasn't to
be uh you know focused on but it was
always going to be on the wind and it
was put in several times at various
levels he's way out there or he's just
around the corner but he was still there
and it was kind of an effective tool to
say that not only were there whips that
would keep the slaves down but it was
also this sort of psychological
manipulation and so that was that was
good stuff that's very effective yeah
there's so much to talk about on this
film there's so much thought in detail
and and you know I think for audiences
to continue to talk about the importance
of this message I think is crucial and
obviously it's I think listening to
Antoine talk about his film why he made
it why it's important to make films that
continue back to this topic I'd love for
Heather to close out for you what was
your takeaway of of of the subject
matter of working with Antoine and just
you know reflecting on the project yes I
for for me what was most important was
that stories like this continue to be
told especially in a time in which you
see school systems trying to remove the
accurate you know
portrayal of history from textbooks in
the curriculum in general with critical
race Theory discussions going on and
that's dangerous because children like
my own who are born you know in recent
years they may think that American
history is having a black president and
Barack Obama but that was quite an
achievement that took several hundreds
of years to accomplish and they need to
know the truth of American history for
African-American children they need to
know how strong their ancestors are and
what I love about this film is that you
see a black man saving himself saving
him family you see him as a hero you see
him as a Survivor and that to me gave me
great inspiration once I read the script
and when I was on set that was the
importance of making this movie
um and working with Antoine and will
what I loved was that they decided early
on that we were going to focus on the
faith of Peter that was a decision that
they made after this script was done
when they sat down and they had
conversations about how did this man
continue to fight how did he continue
his struggle through the swamps with all
these people chasing him and trying to
survive the environments it had to be
his faith in God if anything else and
his love for his family and so even
though you see the brutality of slavery
there's also this really important
message about faith and your love for
family and how that can help you endure
anything
uh so well put thank you guys so much
for coming out tonight I really
appreciate your time thank you all for
coming out and uh thank you yeah tell
your friends it's on Apple TV thank you